can you confirm that the straps are
tight yes but this and now the chains a
lot of people think that magic camp is
just for kids and that's why so many
other people in my class were kids
self-fulfilling prophecy it's um really
for anybody with a dream and a belief in
magic and a little extra time after
school and now Michael the magic will
attempt to escape from extreme bondage
can he do it I don't see how he can I
know how dislocate his shoulder and slip
his arm out oh no everyone now count
down with me
three all right quick thing so is it
true that if you can't get out you don't
want anyone to help you I will get out
oh yes I will
so we shouldn't help you no matter how
much you might beggin plea no all right
just this is getting hot so let's just
do this okay ready three two one go
[Applause]
is everything okay Michael yes I cannot
tell you how I plan to escape other than
by using magic that is the magician's
code separately on an unrelated note if
you happen to find a small brass clue
you